Learner A4: السلام عليكم شباب يعني بالله عليك ونفسي مرة ادخل احس ان في حاجة تنزاني.
Learner A4: أنا هنا.
Learner A4: نور.
Learner A4: موفق.
Learner A6: وعليكم السلام.
Learner A4: وحتى حاسس إن الإسبرانتا دي يعني الأسبوع ده تخطف مرة واحدة كده.
Learner A6: هو. نعم، تسلم أنا.
Learner A4: وبعد غد.
Learner A4: وعمل.
Learner A6: مثلا.
Learner A4: يعني بقالنا جزء بسيط جدا.
Learner A4: وأنا ما بقتش لحد دلوقتي لو ما فيش حاجة حتقول خلاص في حاجة تقولوها أصلا. ولا.
Learner A4: تقريبا أنا وسما بس اللي عم نتكلم يعني.
Learner A6: أول شي أنا عموما أنا في فكرة بس في نقطة انا مش فاهم مفروض أعملي
Learner A6: إنه أولا، إنتو بتقولوا دلوقتي مش مهندسة فرح قالتلك قلتلك نحنا محتاجين نعمل ال
Learner A6: الفويل أو الفيل دايركت صح؟
Learner A6: طب أنا مطلوب مني في الطاست يعني كالمبعوث سواء من سواء من أحمد إني أعمل 4 تنبليت
Learner A6: وأحط في الصين أحط جوا الصين نفسهم سين ديسكريبشن ولا مش فاكر اسمها كده هوت
Learner A6: بناء عليها لكل سين المفروض هديله بالظبط هو حيستخدم إيه وهو من رايح مختار من الأربعة اللي يناسب السين ده ودوهم
Learner A6: فأنا فعلا مش عارف المفروض ولا هنعمل الكلام ده كله.
Learner A4: ، تقريبا الاتنين.
Learner A6: هو ده ازاي كده بقى زي ما هو انت دلوقت.
Learner A4: يعني الإيج هيعمل اتش تي مل جينيراشن.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: وحيبقى قدامه الاختيار يا إما أو
Learner A4: اللي هو ملقاش حاجة في تيمبليس الموجودة فاهمة قصدي.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: يا مساء الخير.
Learner A6: لأنه يكون في كده كده.
Learner A4: ماشي بالطوائد انت السكوب بتاعك وواسع يعني انت مش مقتصر على حتة معينة.
Learner A6: ما دي الفكرة؟ انت لما تسيبني؟ وتوسع لي الدنيا في المجال ده أروح فين واجي منين.
Learner A4: هي الفكرة الوحيدة.
Learner A3: كله.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A3: عندي أي استفسار توضيحي.
Learner A4: تفضل.
Learner A3: هو احنا هو صح.
Learner A6: هو المفروض.
Learner A3: آخذ.
Learner A6: على.
Learner A3: فرومت بياخد يعني ونحن نقوله طلع زي ده انت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: مش فاهم قصدي.
Learner A3: ما هو نحن نعمل زي ده وبتديله.
Learner A4: فعلى.
Learner A3: الاربعة دول هنبعتهم في الفندق اللي هو انت ستعمل زي دول
Learner A3: عشان هو ميعدش يخرب من دماغه او يوسع الدنيا.
Learner A4: عامة ممكن.
Learner A3: بحيث ان هو لازم يحط اللوجو هذا صح كده.
Learner A4: هو حلو إن إنت لسه قايلو ده عشان افتكرت حاجة
Learner A4: إحنا ممكن نقسم الويب بيج زي
Learner A4: يعني في الويب جي ال اصلا اسامه
Learner A4: اللي انت عملته ده انت استخدمت فيه وود جيال صح؟
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: الدكر ويبدي ال أصلا بس عارفين الكنبس
Learner A4: عارفين فنون جميلة مش بيبقى معاهم سكيتش كبير فش كده.
Learner A4: دا تمام، فهو بيستخدم الاتش تي ملك انها تنزف فاحنا ممكن حنقسمها له
Learner A4: اللي هو انت عندك في الفيديو الجزء ده حيبقى الثابت الجزء ده حيبقى الواحد اللي تحت دي كلها اللي حينزل فيها الشرح الحتة الشريط الصغير ده اللي هيبقى في.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي يعني نقدر ان احنا نعمله بس دي نقطه النقطه التانيه
Learner A4: انت كنت بعتلي بقى مبارح علشان ما فهمتش أي.
Learner A6: أو.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A6: أأمل أنا كنت معروف أنا دلوقتي.
Learner A6: أنا لو عملت الأربعة هم.
Learner A4: أي.
Learner A6: إيه هو بيقولك إن إنت في نفسه
Learner A6: عايزني أضيف يعني كل سين هيبقى جوا أو سينجل نفسه أنا المفروض أحط عشان بناء عليها بقولي يفيد تيمبلت ليه أو ديسكريبشن
Learner A6: فده معناته. إن أنا مفروض هو السين نفسه كل سين معايا حديله ديسكريبشن اللي هو حيبقى فيه الوصفة بتاع ال تيمبل بتاعه وبناء على الوصف ده يروح ياخد التمرد يحطه للسين ده
Learner A6: فأنا مش عارف هل ممكن نعمل كده ولا بناءا على الوصف.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A6: كل سينز.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A6: ا.
Learner A4: أنا شايف إن إحنا ممكن نحلها عادي يعني احنا ممكن نعمل.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام انت كدا عندك قبل.
Learner A6: السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: يبقى كده انت بقالك في الكلام ثاني يبقى في صور انت كده خلصت الأربعة
Learner A4: وبناء بقى على اللي داخلة له يبدأ يفل الفراغات دي فجمعتوا قصدي لا انت كان عندك.
Learner A6: هي.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A6: بقالي يا.
Learner A4: دا من صح؟ ولا بس حاجة.
Learner A6: كده كده كده كده هو ده ليه بس.
Learner A4: بالضبط وبناء عليه.
Learner A6: كبار بوين زي قوي ولا قصدهم زي البور بوينت.
Learner A4: صح.
Learner A6: لوجيس.
Learner A6: أنا ممكن أكون بنطال عموما يعني.
Learner A4: أن هو ممكن يقولك يعني.
Learner A1: من.
Learner A4: اها.
Learner A1: أبدأ في الدوكومنتشن امتى.
Learner A4: ابدأ.
Learner A1: عمل المشروع مرفوع على.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A1: على مين صح؟
Learner A4: عالمينه.
Learner A4: خذ المين وخذ البير دي اللي هي بعتاه واعمل الديكومونديشن الان خلصت اللي يعتمد بعتها.
Learner A1: هو موجود.
Learner A4: كانت باعتقادي في البداية خالص عامة. أتوقع هتلاقي برضو على
Learner A4: اتوقع هتلاقي اتوقع هتلاقي أعلى جسد.
Learner A1: تمام.
Learner A4: خذوا وخذهم هم الاثنين على أي على أيم أقوله أنا عايزك تعملي ديكومنتيشن
Learner A4: وبعد ما انت تخلص إحنا إحنا المفروض خلاص يعني بنخلص الشغل، فأي أوديت ثانية قبل قبل.
Learner A1: نعم.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A1: إمم.
Learner A1: من.
Learner A4: أنا بقولك يعني اشتغل اشتغل دلوقتي مع نفسك عادي اشتغل دلوقتي مع نفسك عادي على الحاجات اللي معاك ولما إحنا نخلص خالص ابقى يعمل بس فروعات بسيطة يعني.
Learner A1: تمام.
Learner A4: تمام كده.
Learner A1: تمام ماشي.
Learner A4: ما شاء الله قولها أسامة.
Learner A6: كنت أقول دلوقتي فخلاص يعني هي فعلا الفكرة كويسة البداية والنهاية دول تمام دول حتثبتهم.
Learner A4: يا.
Learner A6: فوق عالشمال والحاجات اللي.
Learner A4: بالظبط.
Learner A6: نثبتها دي خلصت.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A6: آخذها منين. أنا ممكن آخذ على فكرة البداية ده من اللي.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A6: ال.
Learner A4: إحنا ممكن نقدمهم فيزا عادي.
Learner A6: لا أقصد آخذ اللي أوت بتاع الفايل اللي بعثته أساسا المهندسة فرح.
Learner A4: لا اعمل هكذا اعمل هكذا بالضبط.
Learner A6: بأحسن كثير يعني.
Learner A4: ما هو ده قريب منه؟ أنا فكرتي بس الوحيدة اللي عايز أعمل إينوفيشن في الموضوع.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: يعني أنا مش عايز أودي في حاجة سهلة أو أوديك حاجة
Learner A4: بس يعني دي وجهة نظري بس عشان نعرف الأول خلانا نخلص في البيزك أو اللي هو بتاعنا.
Learner A6: دكتور.
Learner A4: وبعد كده نشتكي زي ما إحنا عايزين.
Learner A6: طيب سهل دي باذن الله.
Learner A4: أنا برضه أنا الفكرة اللي أنا مش فاهم برضه تيست بتاعتي يعني أنا.
Learner A6: أساسا.
Learner A4: عايز كونكتيشنز.
Learner A4: بندق.
Learner A4: استحقاقاتك.
Learner A4: بقولك اديها لك.
Learner A4: ما هو.
Learner A4: يقول لك.
Learner A4: أنا خلصت الجزء اللي فات ولا.
Learner A4: انت تخلصوا لوحدك؟ مطلوب منك.
Learner A4: ما هو كان جزء من المطلوب مني للفرح كانت قايلة.
Learner A4: أيوا إنت خلصت بعدو ولا أنت كان مطلوب منك تعمله أصلا.
Learner A4: كتبت من أحمد منصور وكدا لا مكانش مطلوب.
Learner A4: يعني أنا ألريدي مخلص يعني هو قال لي إنت قريتي الفيديو لسنغال أوركستر فونت دخول.
Learner A6: اللي انت بعته.
Learner A4: هو يشتغل.
Learner A6: كل.
Learner A4: بقولك على حاجة.
Learner A4: وقلك.
Learner A4: هولوكوست.
Learner A4: أيوه يا إما أنا بعتلهم أنا كمان كان في مشكلة أصلا. كلمت أحمد منصور.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: كلمته المهم. وثاني حاجة مطلوب مني هو محمد حاتم.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A4: ما هو محمد حاتم في هو عاملهم اللي هو أحمد منصور وساره نادر هو اللي مسؤول عنهم.
Learner A4: فكرهم أي شي.
Learner A4: ما هم.
Learner A3: أنضم إلينا.
Learner A3: يعني يعتبر لهم أذرع تتكلم معاهم محمد البني آدم بتاعهم لكن هم أصلا.
Learner A4: مش قصدي لو أتعامل مع بتأخر عليه اللي أنا بتعامل معه بالظبط.
Learner A4: ما هو ما هو فعلا كده أنا بقولك بس انا عشان ما اعرفش اصل معاه الحاجة فالإيه اللي هو يعني هو مش فاهم حاجة ولا فاهم منه حاجة كلمه اتفقوا مع بعض.
Learner A6: أساسا ولا ده حاجة.
Learner A4: لا الموضوع ده بيبقى
Learner A4: هو المفروض كده نخلص أنا بقولك ال إنتجريشن ده أنا خلصته وقلي كومبليتلي يوزينج ريت أند كونيكتيد ويث بات إن ذي فير ريست فول
Learner A4: ده تمام برضه آخر حاجة مطلوبة منك كلها بعمله
Learner A4: فاينل وورك داير كلي تو ييرمنت 1,000.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: خلاص سهلة وانا المفروض كدا مخلص يعني.
Learner A6: أنا كده أحاول أعمل إيه بقى آخذ كل الكلام اللي موجود و.
Learner A6: أنا أشتغل الأول دلوقتي أنا عموما حطيت السنويه ده
Learner A6: يعني أنا شفت عامله دلوقت دول الاوركسترا نفسه.
Learner A4: حلو أيوا صح.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: أول حاجة الويس ده إحنا مش محتاجينه حاليا عموما بس أنا شايف إن إنت من إتش دي من على طول جوبسكريب
Learner A6: فأنت مش محتاج الوقت.
Learner A4: كامل.
Learner A6: دي بالزبط.
Learner A4: ولا.
Learner A6: فور.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: وفي تاني؟ وفي كومبوزيشن وال.
Learner A4: هو كده.
Learner A6: لي.
Learner A4: ولا مش معمولين في.
Learner A6: ما بالزبط فأنا بتكلم إن هم دول، كدا فإحنا آخر حاجة بنوصلها للأسف.
Learner A4: بالضبط.
Learner A6: أنا مبارح لما كنت بران كان بيقولي إنه يعني بيرفع على بس أنا ما شفتش بصراحة بين الزاي عشان.
Learner A4: عملتوا كونيكت طيب على سوبي.
Learner A6: هو ما هو رفع بالفعل واشتغل المفروض بس أنا بقولك أنا ما عيش يعني ما جربتش أفتح نفسها بصراحة.
Learner A6: هو عملت كونيكت على طول بالسميه ده اللي انت بعته لفيهم.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: بس مش عارف بقى المفروض دلوقتي تبقى هو رفع فعلا وبيرفع صور ولا ما بيرفعش صور.
Learner A4: ده أنا هتأكد منه هو اللي أنا شايفه حاليا المشكله.
Learner A6: عليك
Learner A6: يعني لو لينكات زي اللي هي مش شرط صور يعني عارف اللي هو لينك مثلا زي اللوجوهات والكلام ده أنا ده برضه تمنع يعني أنا مستثمر الكلام عندي إنه حيهدل وبالكلام ده.
Learner A4: هو ده هو رافع ألريدي تعال ناخد ده مثلا
Learner A4: أبدأ معلمك
Learner A4: في مشكله هو يرفع ألريدي صور بس مش الصور بجد.
Learner A6: أمال.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: قال لك يعني.
Learner A4: هيه.
Learner A4: الو.
Learner A4: في الدفع. تمام.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: بلاش جدا سوا.
Learner A4: تعال هنا متى
Learner A4: ودي صورة تانية هو تقريبا.
Learner A4: الفعلي مشان يطلعلي عليها.
Learner A4: بقى الكلام دا بنعمله عرفت.
Learner A6: هو
Learner A4: حاييم. عرفت فده المفروض ده اللينك بتاعك.
Learner A4: دي مثلا دي احتمالية كبيرة اللي هي ممكن تكون صورة دي نفس الكلام انت الباقي الكلام دا
Learner A4: بارد
Learner A4: طب جماعة ينفع حاجة بس ينفع كلكوا دلوقتي تخشوا على السوبر وتعملوا لينك بال دوتيفيز اللي انا شغال بيها.
Learner A6: ما أنا فتحتها.
Learner A4: صح.
Learner A4: اللي انت بعتهولي مبارح كدا؟ انا شغال بيه.
Learner A4: بس بس انا عايزكوا تشوفوا الداتبيز نفسها.
Learner A6: أنا أنا عايز أعرف.
Learner A4: اللي انت بعته صح؟
Learner A4: لا لا خش على طوبة الفيزا عادي.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: خلينا كده نجرب من أكاونتش معاكم.
Learner A4: أه فارق قيامي؟ يا هلا هو مفروض يبقى اسمه بيتوين تو ولا زي ما هو كده.
Learner A4: اليوري ال في ولا عادي دوت إيام دي فايت ماشي.
Learner A4: زي زي ما هم موجودين.
Learner A4: واللي.
Learner A4: موهبة.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A4: أيوة لا يباليين بص عندي عاملين إزاي.
Learner A4: إمم أيه
Learner A4: فرنش فرنش.
Learner A4: على الكويت.
Learner A4: إنت غردت ولا
Learner A4: يا عمنا يا عمي ده لينك ده ليه هو مش ليك.
Learner A4: انت انت خش على سوبر فيزا عادي.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: وربنا وعاد الله.
Learner A4: معلش خدامس.
Learner A4: يا عمي عايز خش عايز بصي على أي أكاونت بصي على أي أكاونت.
Learner A4: تمام وبعدين.
Learner A4: معناها اكتشف.
Learner A4: عشان أنا كاريت أكاونت وما عملش حاجة بعد كده خدت ال.
Learner A6: من ضمن ال تيم ولا
Learner A4: يوريل نسيت جبن برشفت إي.
Learner A4: وأنا قاعدة.
Learner A4: طيب هو انا مش المفروض اكلم بالزبط مسبحة ورقم معي.
Learner A4: المفروض اللي انتو ترتبوا مع بعض.
Learner A4: عشان أكلمه مصطفى باهي هو الفكرة من عندي أصلا يعني درنا اللي بيطلع لي أبعته شد.
Learner A4: هني طيبة.
Learner A4: طيب ثواني لا تقريبا تقريبا عرفت أعمل إيه
Learner A4: ما بين فين فين فين فين يا فندم ده سلامة.
Learner A4: أنا منزعجة.
Learner A3: بص يا عمر انا بكلم عمر الخالد
Learner A3: هو نحن شغالين مع بعض بحيث ان نخرج احسن اساس ممكنه لان انا اعمل قبلك وانت شغال بعدي وبعدها نسلمهم الشغل الذي خرجنه وهم يعملوا.
Learner A4: يعني يبعتلي.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A4: بتاعه معلش.
Learner A3: معلش.
Learner A4: جرج.
Learner A4: كل 1 شغال بيه علشان أعمله.
Learner A3: على قد هف ولا اليمين.
Learner A4: شو.
Learner A4: شغال بيه علشان عشان أعمل.
Learner A3: ماشي هبعتلك وين.
Learner A4: اذا تقييمك.
Learner A3: ولا أنا محتاج.
Learner A4: أوي.
Learner A3: طيب.
Learner A4: فهمتي.
Learner A3: بعتلك.
Learner A4: قيمتي لأ بس.
Learner A4: سمعك معلش.
Learner A4: آيدي.
Learner A4: بلدان.
Learner A4: بقولك علشان كان عندي صحابي نزلهم السعودية معاك يعني.
Learner A3: عمر سايز اشتغلتوا بالليل مع.
Learner A4: ماشي طب يعني معرفش ممكن ابى اعرف الناس لإنت تعرفها.
Learner A4: بحاول.
Learner A6: لا ينشر.
Learner A4: ما هم لو يلعبوا باسكت او في الشله بتاعت سي اس ممكن اعرفهم
Learner A4: ممكن أعرف أسامي حتى بس مش لازم أعرفهم شخصين اننا في الجامعة كلية.
Learner A4: إمم طيب هو لحد معين من الاشتراكات يا جماعة معلش خلينا ومهدي ميسكي كويس فوي.
Learner A2: ,
Learner A4: أنا حقيقة.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي هو شوية يعني أخلص الجزئية بس نخلص الجزئية بتاعت الأسس وال سيمبل
Learner A4: وبعد كده خرج حد ودخلك لأنه هو المفروض عندي حد معين يعني.
Learner A2: قرنفل.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A4: تمام بس انت كده الجزء بتاعك شغال تمام يعني عندي في
Learner A4: في الفايلز أو في الريبو نفسها انت عندك الكلام شغال عادي يعني.
Learner A2: طب أنا عايز اعرف مطلوب مني حاجة جديدة لأن هم تقريبا بعتولي نفس التذكر اللي أنا عامله يعني ما بعتوش حاجة جديدة.
Learner A4: أو أنت.
Learner A4: والله أنا أنا عملت.
Learner A2: أنا نفس البويز أوفر برضو بس هو لو لو حتشغلوا ود أو زي ما أنا عادي ولا لأ.
Learner A4: هو انت تمام هو انت ال فونكشن بتاعتك اللي انت اصلا صح؟
Learner A2: صحة.
Learner A4: طيب خلاص انت الجزء بتاعك زي الفل قلهم انا مخلص الجزء ده لو في حاجة تانية ممكن اعملها.
Learner A2: جزر الفول.
Learner A4: تمام الشغل بتاعك هوت يعني ما شاء الله يعني مليل الجهاز هي كلها في 1
Learner A4: بس خلاص.
Learner A4: مصطفى انتهيالي قبل ما عمري بعد سنة.
Learner A4: دخلت على دخلت.
Learner A3: المفروض شغالين ورا بعض اللي انا فاهمه الموضوع ان هي برضو ده صح كده.
Learner A4: معلش يعني انت المفروض استنى انت تعمل حاجه وانا حكمل.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A4: وسلاح.
Learner A3: لا لا، خلص إحنا إحنا المفروض إن أنا خلصت شغلي وانت خلصت شغلك
Learner A3: ونحن الاثنين نحاول يعني نخرج او نراجع على شغل بعض ونخرج باحسن صوره ممكنه لانه انت تريد تحسين. لو انا ارى ونحكم عليها لو هي تمام تمام لو نحسن سفر انت فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: هو ده اللي مكشوف في التاسعة.
Learner A4: بالضبط بالضبط.
Learner A4: النواحي.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: نانسي كواليتي تلفزيوني بالضبط انا ساقول انا.
Learner A3: انا بس عايز اعرف انت شغال حاجة ثانية.
Learner A3: ثاني حابب دخل إمم.
Learner A4: ألو.
Learner A3: قبل حاجة غير أو حاجة.
Learner A4: لا، لا.
Learner A4: مش عارفها شفت مكانه يعني أنا مبارح اصلا بكلمتي المنهج اللي في باري أصلا
Learner A4: هو اللي جابلي اصلا الانترياشون بتاع سبرينس.
Learner A4: ممتاز.
Learner A4: يعني اللي أنا فاهمه إنه سبرينس أصلا الشركة وعملوا.
Learner A4: 1,000.
Learner A3: ماشي.
Learner A4: إمم
Learner A3: ماشي و كمل.
Learner A4: أنا مش سامعك والله.
Learner A3: بقولك سامعني.
Learner A4: كم العمر. كم.
Learner A4: مش أنا كنت بقلكوا ايش قلت نجمع ونشتري قال لي ما فيش الكلام ده.
Learner A3: والله أنا مبارح برضه قلت كده حتى عمر قالي ما تظبطش لأ هو أكيد ما فيش إن إحنا نجمع من بعض ونعمل الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: قال لي لا هو تابعين.
Learner A3: الشركة أقل حاجة تقدمها لك الشركة اللي إنت شغال فيها أو.
Learner A4: هو يا جماعة.
Learner A3: انت عندك شغل
Learner A3: وهم عملوا هكذا، بالفعل لكن لا اعرفش يعني هم ادونا نموذج عظيم. كان شغال حلو جدا خلصت
Learner A3: طب والمالي طب أنا أشوف دي
Learner A3: انت فاهم قصدي يعني انتو انتو للشركة ولا بالشركة لأ.
Learner A4: مستوى.
Learner A4: أنا سألت عن حوار الإفوآس ده قال لي على دول نبات في السد.
Learner A3: ماشي أنا تقريبا ما اعرفش الغروب.
Learner A4: ماهو وصلات بس أنا لسا انبسطت عليهم يعني لسا كنت كنت لسه بقوله 5 دقايق.
Learner A3: كلهم هاي وين مت وفي ناس لو كان كلهم حيبقوا ليميتد وفيهم حاجات
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: أصل أسأل على حاجة يعني ما تخلصش معايا من غير ما ما كنش شايل هم الكوتة.
Learner A3: ما هي دي المشكلة مهو؟ انا مشكلتنا الوحيدة.
Learner A4: ما هو بعث لي دور على أساس إن دول يعني.
Learner A4: تو باي باس يونايتميدز.
Learner A4: هذا.
Learner A3: بس اللي انت تبعتهم؟ أنا آخدهم عندي كوفي.
Learner A4: عارف إيه.
Learner A3: ناخذهم عندي كوفي ونقعد نحطهم ونشوف
Learner A4: معرفهمش أنا عارف.
Learner A3: انا كده بقلك نعمل كده طيب اذا نحب نشتغل سوا.
Learner A4: بص هو أنا بصراحة أنا ما أعرفش هو أنا يعني أنا شغال أنا مع ومش عارف
Learner A4: يعني أنا برن أنا أنت أنا.
Learner A3: طب انا ممكن اعرف انت يعني مش عارف انت شغال وبيعمل أسد ولا بتعملي بيسود.
Learner A4: أنا المفروض.
Learner A3: ماشي فإنت باني كباش ام كومبولانت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: ماكين.
Learner A3: يعني أنا عامل أنا عامل عامل إيجنت بياخد استرافتو.
Learner A4: أنا بصراحة يعني مش حاس.
Learner A3: عشان كدا انا بحاول استفسر يعني طيب يا عمر.
Learner A4: ممكن.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: لك.
Learner A3: اللي بعدنا
Learner A4: بعدك إنت.
Learner A3: يعني بعد الاسر.
Learner A4: ما فيش حاجة بعد الاتصال الاسس المفروض اللي هو بيجمع الاسست بناء على الكونتكس اللي هو دخل فيه
Learner A4: وبناء عليها نعمل جينيراشن.
Learner A3: حلو قوي يعني الاسس ده عبارة عن ديسكريبشن للصور والحاجات اللي ممكن تبقى موجودة والايكرز والكلام ده صحيح؟
Learner A4: المفروض اللي هو يبقى الصور نفسها والكلام ده.
Learner A3: المفروض يبقى الصور نفسها اها.
Learner A4: هو ده من اعتقادي يعني.
Learner A3: إنجليزي.
Learner A4: ده.
Learner A3: عشان كده أنا بسأل هو إنت بتطلع يعني.
Learner A4: اللي أنا فاهمه ان مسكرفس بس أنا مش مش إمبورتوسور ولا
Learner A4: بصي يعني خلي بالك شغال بفهم الدنيا دا كان.
Learner A3: أنا أشكيك.
Learner A4: كلام.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: واللي. انت تعمله مش مهم يبقى بلاك بوكس مش تمام يعني بصراحة بس.
Learner A4: أنا ما.
Learner A3: مساكن الأرض.
Learner A4: باخذ التكن.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: تذكر ماشي عموما يعني.
Learner A3: الله.
Learner A4: أنا بعتلك.
Learner A3: حلو طيب بتاعتي.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A3: ماشي
Learner A3: انت بتبعت حاجة أومس صح؟
Learner A4: لسه.
Learner A3: شكرا.
Learner A4: أنا كنت في الشارع.
Learner A3: تمنيك.
Learner A4: ما أنا بقول الشغل.
Learner A3: حلو قوله اشرحلنا بس الموضوع بلاك بوكس
Learner A3: الدنيا عباره عن فونشونال اساسيه عباره عن
Learner A3: عشان انا مش عارف انت بتطلع أسست
Learner A3: يعني تخرج صور وايكونس او تخرج وهو يبقى في الاتش تي ام ال فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: يعني خليك معايا لو انت كتبت.
Learner A4: قولت
Learner A3: الله يعطيك العافية.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A3: ماشي بقولك بقى انا تصوري اليس جينريشن
Learner A3: يعني انا تصوري الشخصي ان هو المفروض يكون عباره عن نموذج بياخد ال ويبتديشن من اسس
Learner A3: عشان تدخل بعد كده لمدة هو بيبتدي ويبت انت فاهم قصدي يعني.
Learner A4: من العقل شوي.
Learner A3: سيم إلو الصور و هذه الاشياء هذه اعتقد بتتعمل انت بس تبقى مطلع ديسكريبشن.
Learner A4: إنت إنت اللي بتطلع ديسكريبشن.
Learner A3: امتى أنت مش انت مسؤول عن.
Learner A3: يعني ببساطة.
Learner A4: أنا أنا ما يسمعش قوي عشان كده أنا بحاول ألقط معك.
Learner A3: طيب هو انت ما تسمعش دي صوتي بيقطع ولا مش واضح.
Learner A4: لا، أنا عندي مشكلة.
Learner A3: يعني الف سلامة ولا هذه مشكله سماعه أقول لك الو السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: بس أنا مش عارف أسمعها.
Learner A3: شرف المساواة.
Learner A4: وأنا بكلمك.
Learner A3: طب تحب أعلي صوت شوية.
Learner A4: لا، أنت ممكن.
Learner A3: خليني اقولك انا بس محتاج اعرف انت الموديل بتاعك بيعمل بالضبط يعني انا تصوري عن الموضوع اللي انت ما بتصلحه سوى
Learner A3: انت بتطلع ديسكريبشن لصور وبعد كده المودر اللي بعدك بياخدها يعمل لها
Learner A3: هذا تصوري، لكن انا لا اعرف فعليا انت بتاخد وتطلع
Learner A4: ما انا بقولك انا باخده وبحاول ألقط وانا اعمل، لكن ما باخدهاش زي كده وانا بعمل فهمت يعني.
Learner A4: السلام علي بلقسم الوضع.
Learner A3: حلو حابب انك تقول لي انت شغال مع اي عشان انا حابب استخدم موضوع بشكل.
Learner A4: إننا.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: المفروض إننا بفك بلين بتاع ال إي آي جينيريسيد برومبس.
Learner A3: حلو.
Learner A4: المفروض أي أوتو البرومت سيمبلت مورك ديفيرن موديلز
Learner A4: مش مش يعني أنا في كلمة وقع معايا وعمل أعمل بس حتتكي ودي مش مش مجمعة قوي.
Learner A3: هي علاقته لسوريا.
Learner A4: دولتين.
Learner A3: إيه علاقتو أو.
Learner A4: مع الحتة دي.
Learner A3: عشت مشط طيب تحب تجمع ونعمل معاد لميتين تاني.
Learner A4: ماشي معلش معاك عادي.
Learner A3: هبعتلك حبعث.
Learner A4: انا لا الدنيا بس إيه يعني الفكرة مش واضحة عندي الدنيا قصدي.
Learner A3: على الشغل اللي قبلك والشغل اللي بعدك وإيه اللي بيتعمل عموما وتبقى عارف انت اللي هو بيطلع نموذج بتاعك والدنيا تعمل يعني بتاخد فكرة كده عن الموضوع عشان تناقش براحتنا بالليل.
Learner A4: هو أنا ممكن على فكرة هنا في بيتين خلاص هيقفل ولا
Learner A3: ميتين ساعة.
Learner A4: هو ما موجود بس في حاجة بس معايا.
Learner A4: هو مؤخرا.
Learner A3: ماشي خلص.
Learner A4: سلمت المفروض انا اسامة نوتر بعدين ماشي أنا ممكن أسألكوا ولو في حاجة.
Learner A3: معلش قبل ما تمشي بس وانتو اشتغلتوا بالليل.
Learner A4: لا، أنا.
Learner A3: الله.
Learner A4: مو صعبة يعني.
Learner A3: لا عادي ما أقدرش حاجة بس لو اشتغلتوا بدخلني بحيث إن أنا برضه أبقى فاهم الدنيا أكثر من كده يعني.
Learner A4: معمر.
Learner A3: زليفة
Learner A3: بحيث ان انا عشان احنا بس اللي هو كلها فأنا لو عندي فكرة أحسن عن اللي بعدي أقدر أحسنلك الشغل. عندي أنا شوية كمان.
Learner A4: أنا أنا بالنسبة لي والله بجد يعني أنا ما بحبش فيرتش ولا عشان كده بحس أحسن بكتير.
Learner A3: يوريك.
Learner A4: هذا.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A3: تحليل الوضع.
Learner A4: وننزل نشوف الدنيا. الحوار لما أحسن بكتير يعني.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: والله عارف إحنا ممكن واحنا بنجمع في آخر أسبوع ننزل لو انتو عايزين.
Learner A4: هو أنا تمام والله ممكن أجيلكم القاهرة يعني.
Learner A3: القاهرة.
Learner A4: أنا سندري.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A3: انتي.
Learner A4: انت قعدت الإسكندرية.
Learner A4: انا في اسكندرية،
Learner A3: أكتوبر.
Learner A4: يعني أنا فطور.
Learner A3: وأنا في أكتوبر.
Learner A4: انت دكتور.
Learner A3: لا بكتبش ده عمر خالد اللي انت مكتوبه صح؟
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A3: فين توك.
Learner A4: الحيطة.
Learner A3: أوكي، لا، أنا على طريقي الواحد كومباوند
Learner A4: لفين.
Learner A3: إنت عارف.
Learner A4: وراء الكومبونز مصر.
Learner A3: لا مش من وراء في الناحية مش لازم اقول عنواني.
Learner A4: ناحية ثانية ولا وراء.
Learner A3: أيوة أيوة لا لا ده مو مصلحته عن طريق الواحات نفسه فيعتبر إحنا لو حابب.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: عمر درغام وحتنزل القاهرة قريب إحنا أقرب حاجة لي من اسكندرية لأن أنت عشان كده كده.
Learner A4: والله يا عايزين تتجمعوا فين وما تقلقش يعني صحابي كلهم هناك.
Learner A3: ولذيذ.
Learner A4: أكتوبر الجيزة.
Learner A4: أيوه.
Learner A4: كل اللي انت عايزو عادي اصحابي هناك يعني عادي.
Learner A3: خلاص لو هنتجمع يوم او كده في او بعد الدنيا انا ما عنديش اي مانع يعني اجابه.
Learner A4: هو كده كده المفروض اللي هو الديمودي ده في الأغلب يعني هيبقى في.
Learner A3: طيب حلو أوي.
Learner A4: الله يبارك.
Learner A3: نتعرف عليك.
Learner A4: 8 أيام خلاص.
Learner A3: على
Learner A3: حلو جدا حلو جدا خلاص بص عمر يا خالد أنا حاسس إن إنت محتاج يعني محتاج تاني أنا ما عنديش ما عنديش مشكلة ممكن تبعتلي على سيركل
Learner A3: تكون كده ولو عايز تسألني في اي حاجة دلوقتي عن اللي انا بعمله او انا بطلع وانا بدخل او كدا عشان برضو احنا نعتبر تقريبا بنراجع على بعض او كده
Learner A3: انا ممكن اجاوبك على أي سؤال دلوقتي عايز تسألني مثلا ما فيش أي مشكلة أنت بتحب إيه.
Learner A4: هو أنا مش أنا اللي فاهمه انناسل فيجوال.
Learner A3: عن طريق نحنا بنراجع على بعض
Learner A3: يعني أنا بدخلك ال ديسكريبشن بتاع فيجوالز والحاجات دي تقريبا انت بتعملهاشن يعني
Learner A3: انا بس محتاج اعرف ما هي بالظبط تحديدا يعني.
Learner A4: نصف انا حقولك الموضوع اللي انا افهموا إن أنا شغلانة بيشوف الإي آي بيعملوا هل عشان يدي إينستراكشن وكونسرينتس.
Learner A3: يعني التذكرة اللي بعدها يعني انا ساقول لك على شيء فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: انا في اول تذكيه لي طلب مني ان اعمل
Learner A3: إيجنت بيطلع سين بلاك بطلع الخطة حلو كده التذكرة اللي في.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A3: بطلع اللي هو المشهد حيبقى ماشي ازاي هل يمكن جاكلي تيست يعني شكل جيست.
Learner A4: تو دي.
Learner A3: شكرا.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A3: كنت بتدفعين الأساس قيمة.
Learner A3: مهو ذي فاينينج الأزمة خليني برضه أمشي معاك وحدة وحدة.
Learner A4: معرفش إيه بصراحة يعني.
Learner A3: إيش المشكلة.
Learner A4: إمبليمونت سولڤر.
Learner A3: حلو أي.
Learner A4: هي أوبجيز ده كده تسكن يعني.
Learner A3: اذا انت كده في ترينت ون كنت بتطلع صور
Learner A3: اللي بعدها بتعمل يعني لو الصور تلعب ب كواليتي مش أحسن حاجة نموذج بتعمل يراجع عليها ويعمل إيه أو يغير في بحيث تطلع صور بشكل احسن صح كده لأن أنا كان عندي بنفس الشكل
Learner A3: بعمل.
Learner A4: حياكم يا فرح.
Learner A3: بصراحة قالتلي.
Learner A4: مسافرة. لما سبرينتون؟ قالت أنا عايزة لما عملنا سوري
Learner A4: بلانينغ بتاع سبينت تو قالت لي أنا كنت عايزها منك على الأقل تلاتة أوتبوكس.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: أناس دول المفروض يتسيفوا في الداتايل.
Learner A3: مش كويس.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A3: برئاسة.
Learner A4: يا سلام.
Learner A3: ووتش.
Learner A4: هو المفروض اللتوف دي سيفي.
Learner A3: ماشي.
Learner A4: وأنت لو فتحت.
Learner A3: طيب ممكن تقوليلي.
Learner A4: ، فيديو بس أنا ممكن أبعتهملك.
Learner A3: يا ريت.
Learner A4: ممكن ما اعرفش هو حيبعت كله ولا لأ بس هو هنا في ليميت حبعتهم وحدة وحدة.
Learner A3: ليش
Learner A3: نعم،
Learner A3: تطلعوا ليست آي دي.
Learner A3: بالنسبة للمشاهدين مبروك لا يمكن الوصول.
Learner A3: طيب انت ممكن تبعتلي الصوره نفسها.
Learner A4: شلتلا الإيه تسلم.
Learner A3: الصورة نفسها المخزنة
Learner A4: لا، أنا ما فيش صورة.
Learner A3: ما.
Learner A4: عندي أوت عندي في الترنرد اول شيء انا ابعثها هو بيبعث الكلاميتة دي.
Learner A3: هو.
Learner A3: ال أوتود بتاعك ماشي يعني لا يبقى في صوره من الذي يعمل الصوره.
Learner A4: القصد بتاع
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: معاكم.
Learner A3: بالنسبة لي بس مين اللي بيعمل صورة هل بعدنا.
Learner A4: ما هي الحتة؟ دي؟ أنا مش مش.
Learner A3: دي بقى محتاجين محتاجين.
Learner A4: اللي هو هو المفروض أنا.
Learner A3: ولا أنت أه بالزبط يعني ما هو ده القصد لأ ما هو كدا كدا لو حاجة الصورة هيبقى.
Learner A4: ما هو ما فيش حاجة في حتى يجيبوا لي صور ولا
Learner A4: مش حاجة واضحة. حتى أنا عامل.
Learner A3: يعني انت ال يو أر اللي إنت بعته ده لينك صورة دوت بي إن جي
Learner A3: في حتة اسمها اسست نعدي رقم الصورة والثره.
Learner A4: ما هي كان في حاجة.
Learner A3: في إمم.
Learner A4: كان في حاجة ندى بعتاها متهيألي و أسامة أظن العمر
Learner A4: في حتة اس سي دي فأنا
Learner A4: عشان يبقى كلنا ماشيين مع بعض كانت ندى.
Learner A3: إمم إمم.
Learner A4: الندم السلسلة العادية.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: أنا مش كده الترتيب في حاجة يبعتهالي قالتلي هنمشي بنفس الترتيب ده.
Learner A3: أقولك على حاجة.
Learner A4: ولا مشيت على.
Learner A3: انا ساسال احمد منصور او حسال ساره المفروض ونقارنه باللي معمول ولو كده ممكن.
Learner A4: انت لو حابب انا ممكن ابعتلك الفايل انا عامل سبراس كلها لو عايز ابعتهولك عشان تلقط انا كنت عامل براحتك
Learner A4: لو ينفعكوا حاجة يعني.
Learner A3: لا، ما هو كدا عارفة شغلك فأنا لو سألتها تقولي.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A3: اللي بتصحح لنا.
Learner A4: انا بكلم فيك انت لو انت اللي حابب تعرف يعني.
Learner A3: لا، أنا تمام أنا بس أنا بس عايز أعرف نقطة واحدة. هو انتميت الصور ولا حاجة.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A3: لأن عندي.
Learner A4: وانا قلت رئاسة ما وقف يعني سولڤر فا.
Learner A3: فرنس وتخزنها.
Learner A3: إنت مقدم.
Learner A4: عذرا في النص الصورة ما بيتلاقوا هيك.
Learner A4: شو.
Learner A3: انا عملت هكذا مش عارف مين اللي بيعمل الصور يعني انت اسامة ما بيعملوش الصور.
Learner A3: شو يعني ما في جواب.
Learner A4: جمال.
Learner A4: سيناتور.
Learner A4: قل لي درمان ما فيش حد بيقولهالي أصلا.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: فخليك.
Learner A4: عمر والله.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A3: انت الصور انا شفت صور شفت حد صاير صور مين هو.
Learner A4: ما فيش حد.
Learner A3: أما الصور بتاعتنا بتيجي منين.
Learner A4: ما هي دي الفكرة ما فيش ثور بتطلع
Learner A4: عشان كدا انا بقول المفروض الاسد.
Learner A3: المفروض ده في يد عمر خالد.
Learner A3: يعني عمر كيد هو اللي بيطلع صوت.
Learner A4: ده المفروض يعني ما هي الأساس هي ده معناها يعني.
Learner A3: ما هو فاهمه عشان كده أنا إيه بحاول أتأكد من ده.
Learner A4: معنا.
Learner A3: لا لا فاهمه بعض.
Learner A4: البراء.
Learner A4: أنا متألف دايريكت لأن أنا كم.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي عامة خلاص يعني.
Learner A4: أنا
Learner A3: البعض.
Learner A4: ممكن أبقى الأسد بس ممكن يبقى أحد ثاني هو اللي.
Learner A3: معناتها.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A3: باربر.
Learner A4: ما فيش حاجة بقى كده فأنت شوف بقى
Learner A4: شوف حوار الصور ده حاول تبدأ
Learner A4: وانا برضو من ناحيتي هحاول اشوف حاجة المفروض يعني اللي هي تخزن الصور على طول من غير ما هي تبقى لينك.
Learner A3: ده في حاجة.
Learner A4: أول.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: إننا.
Learner A4: مش سامع.
Learner A3: أنا.
Learner A4: ده مفروض بيه.
Learner A4: بعد كده مش نافع.
Learner A4: أه.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A3: بس وانت وعمر الكلب.
Learner A4: لا، لا خلاص ما هو أصل إنتو بتسكتوا بعد كده أتكلم خلاص.
Learner A3: انا كنت مكان لو في حاجة بتخزن الصور في حاجة اسمها زي الاس ثري.
Learner A4: اللي هو ده كده صح.
Learner A3: بخزن فايلات قهوة.
Learner A4: تمام هشوف ازاي هل انتو عرفتوا تعملوا للكلام ده عرفتوا تعملوا اسس لل أورجيشن.
Learner A3: فرنش.
Learner A4: مقبول.
Learner A3: هبعتلك الجيشن هناك، صح؟
Learner A3: هبعتلك الديفن على هناك يعني بتاعي هيبقى بتاعتك صح كده.
Learner A4: هو هو كده كده بيطلع لي أصلا يعني من غير ما انت من غير أي حاجة أنا عملت.
Learner A3: اللي هو.
Learner A4: العالية.
Learner A3: عليك.
Learner A4: هو 60.
Learner A3: تمام عظيمت.
Learner A3: طبعا ما حصل خلاص مش محتاج مني حاجة.
Learner A4: انا بس عايزكم كلكم تعملوا عليها أكسس علشان كلكوا تبدؤوا ترنوا الفايف لاين فده نطلع بأحسن حاجة فاهم.
Learner A3: تمام بس.
Learner A4: ديمبطة.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: ايوه جرب بقى كده خش هنا يعني ينفع تعمل شيرس كريم.
Learner A3: يش.
Learner A4: عايز نعمل
Learner A4: اعمل سكرين كدا.
Learner A4: أنا فتح 3 شاشات عشان جاي أقولك.
Learner A4: اعمل اللي عندك.
Learner A4: اللي عندك انت.
Learner A4: اللي عندك مش انت دلوقتي فاتح سوبر.
Learner A4: عندنا.
Learner A4: مسيرة سكرين.
Learner A4: بس كده عين.
Learner A4: تسلم عيونك.
Learner A4: فأنت لازم تقفل عشان أفتح.
Learner A4: فعلا.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A4: أخذناه.
Learner A4: بشكر دا ربنا يخلقه لنا والله.
Learner A4: والله والله.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A4: ماشي اضغط بقى على الليكود دي يعني بص اضغط على الحتة دي كده
Learner A4: أيوة خش على اضغط على سبرينتس فيديو خش على بعديها بقى اللي على الجنب.
Learner A4: اليمين ولا شمال ولا
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A4: على دي
Learner A4: لا، لا ليه رجعت تاني اللي عالشمال خالص.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A4: يا إما سوق اهو،
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A4: أيوا بس كده إضغط بقى على فيديو بس خلاص ما بتتدخلش.
Learner A4: ، ماشي.
Learner A4: عوض بالي بس كده كده.
Learner A4: طيب اسرح.
Learner A4: يعني خش كده يمين شوية راح على اليمين.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A4: أهو حتلاقي عندك أدي عندك داتا تيم داتا تخش على تخش على هناك برضه ادي الاسود ده.
Learner A4: مش من.
Learner A4: دي كل دي كل الحاجات اللي طلعت معايا فأنتو خشوا واعملوا إعملوا وشوف الحاجات اللي هتتخذ والحاجات عليش.
Learner A4: لما إجا رن عندي هاي سامع هنا.
Learner A4: أه.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: شو بس حياخد يعني.
Learner A4: أنا مكن
Learner A4: بالتمام.
Learner A4: آسف، شكرا.
Learner A4: عامل رمل أوركستر فايل.
Learner A4: دي.
Learner A4: إيه بص.
Learner A4: أنا لسه عامرن.
Learner A4: ده للاسد بتاع جيم ما هو مش واخد جيب آي دي.
Learner A4: أنا مش سامعك معلش. أنا آسف.
Learner A4: بقولك هو مش واخد جو آي دي لازم ياخذ جو باي دي.
Learner A4: أنا بحاول أسمع خط.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: اكتوى بس.
Learner A4: ينفع طالما اخش تاني بعدين سمعني.
Learner A4: ممكن نخش إيه.
Learner A4: بعدين.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: ازاي ترن معرفش إيه آخر تعديلات.
Learner A3: بعدين ده أساسي يعني انت كده كده لازم نيجي بعدين.
Learner A4: لازم ماشي احنا ممكن انت.
Learner A4: هو أنا بس عايز أفهمت عشان أنا يعني واضح.
Learner A4: عايزين فيجول عايزين فيجوال.
Learner A4: طيب إنت إنت مبارح قلت لنا كم حاجة لما تسحب.
Learner A4: أيوه دي كانت كومنت لأسامة ما ما كانش لها أي علاقة بالشغل بتاعك.
Learner A4: ما أنا قصدي لو في حاجة زي علاقة بينا كلنا.
Learner A4: ميادين كلنا.
Learner A4: الحاجة. كلنا.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A4: لا من ناحية الأسس لا
Learner A4: انت لو عملت مزبوط طبعا لو لقيت أي في سمح يعني وطبعا.
Learner A4: المفروض.
Learner A4: ولو طلع ديسكريبشن مضبوط كل حاجة مزبوطة المفروض اللي هو حيطلع اللي هي عايزاه بالظبط.
Learner A4: فالكومنت التانية دي كانت في الديزاين بتاع الفيديو نفسه حيبقى ماشي ازاي
Learner A4: لأن هي كان عندها كومنت معرفتش ال باكجراوند عايزاها بيضة مش عايزة كل الكلام يطلع مرة واحدة عايزة واحدة هي اللي تطلع فاهم يعني حاجات كده.
Learner A4: هو الفيديو عشان قست ولا أنا في ورد.
Learner A4: ما هو الأسد اللي إنت بتطلعها
Learner A4: اللي انت بطلعها كده كده هي تمام المشكلة مش في الأساس.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: المشكلة في الترتيب بتاعها إزاي هتظهر فاهم
Learner A4: كأنه شغل مونتاج بالظبط يعني أنا كده كده عندي عندي الكلام ده هيطلع الكلام ده هيطلع الكلام ده هيطلع ما فهوش أي مشكلة الفكرة بس الوحيدة ده هيطلع إمتى لوغو تيمبلوس اللي إحنا اتفقنا عليها الكلام ده كله
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: الكلام ده.
Learner A4: لا تبقى طالعة مظبوطة.
Learner A3: غالبا التذكرة بتاعتك بس بتوقف عند لما تطلع لنا الصور وتخزننا في دوت تطلع لنا الصور المطلوبة وتخزن لنا في دوت.
Learner A4: مظبوط مضبوط.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A3: اللي بعد كده التعديلات معلش يا عمر دور هو ما أنا آسف.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A3: طيب بعد كده كان عليها التعديلات يعني هي التعديلات اللي قالتها قالتها في الجزء التذكرة بتاعتهم هم
Learner A3: المطلوبة اللي هم يستخدموها في بناء اتش دي ميل بتاعهم
Learner A3: واريد ان اتاكد من هذا الكلام تحديدا؟ لانني لم اقل.
Learner A4: أنت.
Learner A3: ممكن تسأل صورة.
Learner A4: بص حقولك إنت عندك في حاول تخلي
Learner A4: بناء على الكومنت اللي أنا قلتها أو.
Learner A4: صح.
Learner A4: لا لأن انت حتستلم كدا من مصطفى مصطفى لو عمل مضبوط خلاص هي أسست تمام
Learner A4: طبعا فرق كواليتي فرق مثلا لوجو معين أو فيجوال معين ده تمام بس هو الأساسي ال تيم بلانينغ لأن تيم بلانينغ الفيديو عبارة عن سيمز كثير
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي هقول بينظم الكلام ده اللي هو مثلا انت عندك في اول وحدة بيحصل 1 2 3 في ثاني وحده بيحصل 1 2 3 ثالث وحده بيحصل 1 2 3
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي مصطفى انت معاي.
Learner A3: ما عنديش مشكلة عمر إنجمالي.
Learner A4: بناء على
Learner A4: وزي ما قلتلكوا يعني إن شاء الله بس إيه نظبط البيز اللي هي عايزاه وبعد كده نبدأ حاجة بيزو بصراحة.
Learner A3: أنا معاك ما عنديش مشكلة إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: بس إن شاء الله خير.
Learner A3: انا معاك تاني النهارده.
Learner A4: أنا ما عنديش مشكلة تمام علشان نبدأ في الحوار بتاعه.
Learner A3: خلاص.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A3: تبعتولي.
Learner A4: مش عارف ممكن ممكن نكلم محمود منصورة وعادي يعني ممكن نبعت لينك برايفت لبعضو على سيركل زوميغا ده.
Learner A4: على أحمد بقولك إنت.
Learner A4: عادي يعني قل له انت قد الدنيا الجد.
Learner A4: ده.
Learner A3: ببليك.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله.
Learner A3: وهستنى بإذن الله بالليل ويكيند أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي إنت مناسب معاكي.
Learner A3: ما عنديش مشكله انا فاضل اليوم ان شاء الله إنت.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A4: المفروض الدنيا الدنيا تمام.
Mentor A: حلوه يا شباب.
Learner A3: وقت ما يدخلوا.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A4: أهلا وسهلا.
Mentor A: هذا.
Learner A4: مواليد.
Learner A4: انا غدا اجازة.
Mentor A: طيب.
Learner A4: بس.
Mentor A: كنت داخلة أشوف كده وهخروج حتى كنت ما كنتش ناوية. أتكلم بس بما أنكم تعملوا ميتينج تاني بالليل
Mentor A: طبوا بعتولي.
Learner A4: يلا.
Mentor A: ممكن أدخل كده أبص وأخبر.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: لتبعته.
Learner A4: ماشي ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: خلص أوكي.
Learner A4: ماشي بس خلاص ماشي معا ان شاء الله ممكن على تمانية ثانية ونص
Learner A4: يعني كمان ساعتين 3 ساعات كده يعني.
Learner A3: عظيم جدا باذن الله ثمانيه ثمانيه نصفه.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: أنا عشت.
Learner A4: ماشي يا شباب.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: مع السلامة.
Learner A4: أيوة ما يعاونك.